news 8 news now an african-american
museum is in the works for the historic
west las vegas and residents are really
getting behind it yeah jeremy j ford is
at jackson and h street with the story
once dubbed as a thriving area where
only blacks could live and enjoy
entertainment the historic west side las
vegas could be sharing its rich history
in a new museum i feel like the west
side is being left behind due to
the area
and high crime rate but it wasn't always
that way often called the mississippi of
the west back in the 1950s and before
integration blacks were only allowed to
live on the west side where they thrived
in their own community see jackson used
to be like fremont street you go from
here to here here to here across the
street around the corner all of this was
you know we used to hit spots all the
time then in 1955
came the world famous mulan rouge the
first integrated casino in las vegas my
grandmother she used to do hair there
and so i know a little bit about that
they brought in a lot of attraction a
lot of gambling and the community saw a
darker side but the historic west side
also brought a little bit of camping a
little bit of prostitution a little bit
of gambling it brings different
different types of crowds and tourism to
the town so that's why it's hysterical
because it's where it started at with
its rich history and colored past
residents feel a museum might be a great
way to share the story of the west side
if
we put
african
american museum on this side of town it
would draw more of us jeremy j ford live
local now
the city says a comprehensive master
plan will include means of funding floor
plans adequate locations and a clear
vision for the museum and center